any startup that i would want to join
should be a startup that i would invest
in
because at the end of the day when you
join a startup
you're investing so much more than money
uh
uh into it welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20-minute
leaders i'm being joined today by
orian kelev chief revenue officer and
founding team member of own backup
where he leads the company's global go
to market strategy
based in tel aviv ori led the expansion
of own backups global sales organization
from one employee
to what is today over 200 employees
globally
with presence in the united states uk
france israel and australia
orienkalev welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me from the own
backup offices how are you doing
i'm doing great hi michael how are you
doing i'm doing fantastic
especially now i get to have another 20
minutes of inspiration
and learn about some more things that i
still know very little about
and and hear from personal experiences
or the chief revenue officer and
founding team member of own backup
you're leading the companies a global go
to market strategy
but but different from a lot of other
companies here you you're actually
running a team of 200 people that you
helped scale from one person
and you know globally with presence in
the us uk france israel and australia
and i'm excited to pick your brain
not just about sales and marketing but
what is it like growing really an
entire organization within an
organization
that um that it deals both globally
deals with hundreds of employees
it has deals with you know changing
strategies and and
and culture and so a lot of things to
unfold here but first i'd like you to
take me back
your own journey and and what brought
you to to
you know be in a role where you decide
that you're going to lead
the sales and marketing division of the
hyper growth startup
yeah so that's actually a very uh
personal story personal journey uh
started my
i grew up in boston from the boston area
uh
after i graduated from umass amherst i
started working for a venture capital
firm in boston called openview partners
really uh they've done some really great
things since then when i joined the team
was
the firm was actually pretty pretty new
and uh while i was there i was on the
openview labs team which is there
go to market consulting team that works
with the portfolio companies to help
them implement
best practices and we were investing in
early stage
uh b2b tech companies it was sort of you
know
as sas was becoming the next thing all
the new startups at that time were
pretty much sas companies
and so i was helping them implement
best practices and as part of that best
practices and go to markets part of that
i actually became a certified sales
force admin
uh in 2008. and i mean basically what
what we realized pretty early on is that
most companies we were investing either
didn't have a proper crm system
or or were using salesforce and didn't
have it
implemented correctly and they just
didn't have processes that could scale
they didn't have systems that could
scale so that was actually a big part of
my job
uh in addition to sort of go to market
strategy consulting
and so i did that for a while i spent
two two years during that time actually
with a company called intronis which was
a online backup company that we invested
in that was
uh sam gutmann our the ceo of own backup
that was his company
so that's how he and i first met and so
during that time i learned a lot about
building
early stage technology companies i
learned a lot about
the salesforce salesforce.com and the
salesforce ecosystem and i learned a lot
about backup and recovery because of
that
the time i spent working with sam
edentronis and
uh you know years later during that time
i ended up meeting
a very nice israeli girl who is now my
wife
uh she decided uh at some point that we
were gonna move to israel
so we we took some time off uh on the
way and then we moved to israel
and when he got here uh i was you know
starting from scratch essentially and i
had to decide what i wanted to do
so i i basically decided that there was
two routes i was going to take i was
either going to go work for another
vc firm based here in israel or i was
going to go
find uh some some you know smart
uh israeli entrepreneurs to team up with
and
and start a company and so i i
actually that period here uh when i was
interviewing
with with companies and meeting with
entrepreneurs was was actually a super
fun time because
i got to meet so many incredibly smart
people
um that many of which i still keep in
touch with today
uh and that was how i met arielle
burkman our cto
and so he and i met and the the
actually the so the full story is you
know he and i were introduced we
scheduled a meeting and then
about a week before the meeting i got an
email from sam who said hey ori
i heard you live in israel now i'm
coming on vacation with my family
and i'd love to meet up any interesting
companies i should meet with while i'm
there
i'm looking for my next thing and i said
well hey sam we're going to meet with
these guys they do back up for
salesforce
it's right up a rally why don't you why
don't you just come join me
so he took he took a few hours off of
his vacation and
uh and we ended up all meeting together
at a coffee shop in herzeglia
wow and then yeah and and when was this
so that was in the fall of 2014 i think
that was october of 2014
and you know we did we did um
you know a bit of negotiation and due
diligence and stuff and
i guess the way i thought about it was
uh
any any startup that i would want to
join should be a startup that i would
invest
in because at the end of the day when
you join a startup
you're investing so much more than money
uh
uh into it and so that was really how i
thought about it so we did our due
diligence i spoke with a lot of
my contacts from boston from the
salesforce system and
the story made a lot of sense the
product was great
it was you know right product the right
place at the right time
and you know we just had to execute
amazing amazing yeah and so tell me a
little bit about
your thought process as you're deciding
you know where you want to be focusing
a lot of your time you've been there for
more than six years now so obviously
the due diligence ended up with you
choosing to invest your your
your time and you know a big part of
your life into this
what were some of the things that made
you decide this is the right thing for
me to do
on a personal level
um that's a good question i i think
you know it's there's only so many
um i guess stages in life where you can
make that uh
take that leap of faith i mean
especially at that
stage in in my life i wasn't uh
you know i wasn't exactly i couldn't
exactly retire at that
at that point in my life so it was a it
was a risk
and you know there's only so many times
in life where you can
put yourself in that type of situation
and go head on and you're either gonna
either gonna hit it and knock it out of
the park or you're gonna you know
fizzle out and go back to a more more of
a normal lifestyle than
an entrepreneurial lifestyle so i was
you know lucky enough to to be in that
situation and i
felt it was you know the right
if i wasn't going to do it then i don't
know if i ever would have done so
and that was a that was amazing one of
the factors
and so you're joining you're joining own
backup
and walk me through some of the under
your understanding of
you know what is what is your job going
to entail and and how perhaps that
that evolved you know over these past
six years because i'm sure your job has
evolved tremendously
as the company grew and as you grew your
team from one to two hundred
what were what was that growth like and
and how did you personally deal with
that
you know holding both yourself
accountable but also understanding that
the job description that you thought you
were taking on is actually
changing pretty quickly
yeah that's that's that's a good point
it's true i mean
i have to say it didn't initially it
didn't i wasn't surprised i sort of knew
what i was getting myself into because
because i had been around that but um i
think i i
i was pretty lucky in the sense that you
know we joined
sen when sam and i joined ariel was sort
of the technical founder
sam is sam is a business guy um
he's very well-rounded and i was really
focused on go to market
so a lot of founders don't have that
luxury they have to be
doing a little bit of everything and so
join joining as like a
sales oriented founder a sales founder
what
is kind of unique um i think
so i was at first really just focused on
on
you know go to market i was writing uh
blogs for the website i was writing
content for the website i was
i was cold calling customers i was
responding to inbound leads
and because of my background in in
salesforce
i actually maintained my my admin
certifications for a while
i could actually talk shop with our
customers i could have very
deep technical conversations with our
customers and so i was doing tech
support calls and
you know of course rel was uh you know i
would have the customer in one ear and
ariel in the other ear and he's
you know typing things into his into his
you know matrix
in his computer uh helping troubleshoot
stuff but
um you know at first i wore pretty much
any customer facing hat
uh you know for the first almost year
um i heard i hired our first
uh couple of sales people uh
in i think they i think in august or
september of
2015 and our you know the first
salesperson i hired was uh
emma van diegner she actually leads our
enterprise team today
uh and she and i actually had worked
together at openview
so we had stayed in touch and uh
you know i i always saw her as a really
good
uh salesperson so uh she was one of the
first people i brought on board she's
still here today she's leading our
enterprise team doing a fantastic job
uh but once she came on then i continued
she focused on the u.s market i hired
her in uh
she was working out of boston at the
time uh
she focused on the u.s market i
continued to focus on
uh the european market
but then i was also her sales engineer
so i was still wearing all the different
hats
um and then slowly you know we grew the
team from there
i think uh we got our first you know we
did our first sort of mini
uh mini sales bootcamp in 2016
uh when we hired a group of about
i think it was four or five additional
uh sales reps
and uh two new sdrs
and uh we flew everyone out to to new
jersey
uh where our office was which at the
time we were working out of
out of uh sam's dad's company's office
uh which was which was fun so we all got
together in in the conference room there
and um we ran our first sort of sales
boot camp
uh which was great and then it was more
happening
i have to say that just from from that
short description you know i can't
you know i i can assume already just by
hearing you that that you really
remember that
that day and you really remember that
boot camp and and what it was like and
and you know a part of me also believes
that it that's probably not necessarily
the case for every boot camp you run in
every meeting or every
or each it sounds like this was a pretty
pretty big
thing that in in your own journey this
this boot camp right
this learning experience i i think it
was it was a good
it was a good uh
it was our you know it was the first
time we had we had a sales team really
wow so that was that was cool
what did you learn from from onboarding
these
four or five new sales reps and the sdrs
and
because the i it's not i'm almost trying
to you know
make it an as a similar analogy to you
know growing a product for as a company
that
you're building the product you're
finding product market fit the test for
that is sort of this boot camp and
there's onboarding and once you find
that
you're entering a growth stage where you
go okay now we're 10 and now we're going
to get to 200
and you sort of iterate on this process
but that first
big client to that first big
breakthrough like the hot
bring on board the first few people
that's really the big learning
experience right
yeah so it's it's interesting this
it's very similar to the work that i did
at openview
um and so it wasn't it wasn't that
foreign to me it was
definitely an amazing experience but it
was
a lot of it was you know just another
taking a a page straight out of the the
textbook that i used when i worked with
many of our portfolio companies then so
it was it was
uh familiar but it's different i mean
it's different when you're a
consultant or an investor than when
you're
you know right uh the founder of the
company and you have
a lot more skin in the game yeah you
know per you're personally invested
uh you know so that was that was a great
uh feeling
amazing and so the the growth then
20x really from that point
what is that like i mean i i obviously i
can't even attempt
trying to get you to answer that within
a few minutes but take me through some
of the non-trivial things that you
learned that perhaps i as a young
entrepreneur
aren't even thinking about when i'm when
i'm trying to picture what what growing
an organization like that
is
yeah it's hard to it's hard to pick one
it's hard to pick one thing
right um but there's there's a lot i'd
say
uh there's a few there's a few things
that are that are really important
uh to keep in mind for young
entrepreneurs first of all
i think most entrepreneurs think they
have product market fit way before they
actually do
so you don't necessarily have to rush to
to hire your first sales team it's
actually really good to stay
to stay close to the customers
um for a little while and
that one of the reasons i i hired my
first few reps
in the u.s um was so that was so that i
could continue to focus on emea
and then we actually did hi you know
we considered not hiring uh people in
emea
or in israel i was based in israel at
the time considered not hiring people in
israel at all
but i actually insisted on hiring at
least one salesperson here
that i could stay close to and that was
that was also really helpful
wow but as you bring on as you bring on
the team and as you hire people
the things are really important to keep
in mind are
you know making sure you have really
clear uh definitions around
who's your ideal customer and what who
is your buyer persona
and like like really who who are those
people and what do they care about what
do they think about
what you know what's their day-to-day
language
and making sure that your team picks
that up is super important
and that should feed into almost
everything that should feed into the
people you hire
like you're you you want to hire your
first few people from
uh from that maybe from that ecosystem
maybe from
you know a customer maybe from you know
people who really understand the problem
um
yeah that is also another thing that's
really important i think for early
entrepreneurs is that the first few
people you hire are
you know actually everybody you hire
um makes an impact for better or worse
so uh you know that's another thing i
think it's
most entrepreneurs i don't know if it's
most but
i think you're better off hiring slowly
and hiring great people then rushing to
hit some hiring goal and ending up with
a bunch of you know
not great talent or people who aren't
really going to be good for your culture
as you grow
um right and i'm actually hearing that
that quite quite often
that you know there's a lot of pressure
sometimes that you're supposed to be
growing at a certain speed and you've
raised a certain amount of capital and
the market is responding in a certain
way
and then you're sometimes compromising
perhaps on your hiring habits
and your due diligence on the right
people which at the end might compromise
culture now
from your experience how critical is it
to do that diligence
on the 200th person you know in
comparison to to some of the first few
maybe
at some point as you get to the hundreds
you know maybe you can then fall through
the cracks at some points and just know
to fire fast and so you don't really
have to
to worry too much about that is that
what you found or did you find something
else
um i think you have to do both i i don't
think you can ever just
say you know
we can we can settle right you should
never settle even
even when you're a 50 000 person company
you shouldn't be settling on talent um
i think it's always yeah of course it
depends on the role some roles you might
do more due diligence in
some roles you might do less but you
should always
have high expectations for the people
you're bringing on
because that they're the they're the
people who are going to
make the difference build the company
build the culture or
or ruin it amazing only there's
there's a lot more questions that i want
to that i want to ask and we're just
touching this we're just starting to
scratch the surface on some a lot of the
questions about growth
uh but but i love hearing the your
personal story and the founding story
and and i think that that perspective
also sometimes gets lost in in the hype
and the fame and
and the big numbers uh but at the end
it's you know we're all people
and we all have these amazing
experiences and a lot of difficult
decisions to make and
i think as a young entrepreneur that's
what you know grounds me in this show is
hearing at the end how things started
and
how it was not trivial then it wasn't
obvious and it's not an overnight
success
in this case it's just over six years
which is a long time comparison to what
a lot of people think
and so thank you for the time i have a
few more questions about you
not about own backup or about this
specific journey and i want to take you
back to
middle school or high school what was
your
favorite subject what fascinated you as
a kid
um i had i was so i think my favorite
subject in middle school was
uh probably history
in retrospect yeah i really enjoyed
history
and um i was also very interested in
film
i did a summer program at the new york
film academy and
wow did a lot of home movies with my
friends
but uh yeah very very cool and
uh an inspiration uh any
anybody you know on your journey
personal professional that serves as
some sort of role model or some
a figure of inspiration
um yeah i think i draw inspiration from
a lot of
a lot of different sources um you know
even even in tech you know i i look up
to
to other you know very successful tech
entrepreneurs like
you know mark benioff and and uh
uh even you know bill gates
was someone i even even looked up to as
a kid so seeing what they
what they do today and they're both on
the business
side and also on the philanthropic side
and how they
they actually you know
put actions behind their words
very very cool and what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself
if i were to ask you three words i'd use
describe myself
i think uh curious
um
uh action energetic
i like i like doing stuff i like going
out and doing stuff and then
uh motivated
very very cool ori thank you very very
much
and continue making a huge impact with
own backup and
uh and i'll still continue to think
through what it's like to to grow it to
grow an organization from one to two
hundred
a and globally with all its challenges
um thank you for the inspiration and
thank you for your time take care yeah
my pleasure thanks michael bye
you